this video is about how i do my job and
if i've done this right by the end of
this
you should be able to do it too it's
also sponsored by skillshare more on
that later on the 24th of april 1957 the
bbc broadcast what would turn out to be
the first episode in the longest running
science tv show of all time the sky at
night for many people in the uk at least
the monthly half hour show was the kind
of thing they thought of when the idea
of science communication was brought up
elsewhere you may think of cosmos by
carl sagan for example but that term
science communication
is a little nebulous
especially now cycom for short is about
much more than just tv shows you have
people like hank green making tick tocks
answering questions about science you
have authors like rebecca skloot
producing books like the immortal life
of henrietta lacks and you have youtuber
academics like jordan harrod making
videos about topics in their research
hell this youtube channel my job is all
about communicating science but what is
that and how do you do it
cycom for short is now an academic field
with qualifications available and
professional lecturers and professors
teaching the subject and i want to be
clear that i am not professionally
qualified in the same way that those
lecturers are this video is just based
on my personal opinion informed by me
being trained as a scientist and having
done this job of visual science
communication for several years now one
definition of science communication is
an activity that aims to enhance public
scientific awareness understanding
literacy and culture by building
aeiou responses in its participants a e
i o u standing for awareness enjoyment
interest opinion forming and
understanding and has nothing to do with
old macdonald or his farm that's a lot
of words and concepts all in one go so
perhaps it's best if we briefly go back
to those examples that i gave you to see
how that definition and those outcomes
apply so the sky at night aimed to
increase awareness of different
astronomical phenomena with a little bit
of understanding thrown in hank green on
tiktok is making science more
interesting by making it more enjoyable
rebecca skloot is increasing awareness
of a certain aspect of science and
improving the public's ability to form
an opinion on the social and ethical
side of research while jordan harrid
here on youtube is increasing awareness
and understanding of certain topics in
machine learning
so if you want to be the next hank green
you set your objective of increasing
awareness and enjoyment of science and
you just
do it really well
right
no in my opinion it's not enough to just
look at these outcomes in order to
understand science communication you
really have to understand another
related concept that is
key to how i do all of my work science
capital refers to science-related
qualifications understanding knowledge
about science and how it works interest
and social contacts in simple terms
science capital is how
into science you are so that could be
through formal qualifications like
degrees or it could be from knowing
somebody who works in the science
industry and knowing a bit about what
they do or it could be enjoying hearing
about science in youtube videos or
podcasts a low science capital
individual might not have gone to
university and enjoys watching vlogs on
youtube in their spare time while a high
science capital individual might have a
phd in a science subject and enjoys
listening to nerdy podcasts like more or
less or want you a doctor yet to me the
definition of science communication
provides the why while the definition of
science capital provides the how the two
concepts are inextricably linked when
talking about practically doing cycom
why am i suddenly outside that's because
i want this part of the video to really
stick in your brain and i want that to
happen because i'm about to hit you with
the two big ideas
firstly the ultimate objective of
science communication is to increase the
level of science capital of its audience
and
secondly and more interestingly in my
opinion that effective science
communication needs to be tailored to an
initial level of science capital
perhaps it's easiest to explain these by
going back one more time to these
examples so who is the sky at night
aimed at people who are already
interested in astronomy so a relatively
high science capital audience who by the
end of the show will hopefully be aware
of some topics in astronomy that they
weren't before
meanwhile on tick-tock hank green is
aiming for a low science capital
audience he's aiming for the average
young person scrolling through their for
you page and just every now and again
likes being hit by a little nugget of
science by the end of one of his videos
that audience will think of science as
being more interesting and more
enjoyable and then to give one more
example in the immortal life of
henrietta lacks rebecca skloot is aiming
for kind of a middling science capital
audience the average non-fiction reader
who by the end of the book will have
been given enough information about
cancer science and the relevant social
factors to have formed an opinion on
quite a complicated bit of science and
of course you can get more granular than
this within low science capital you have
some people that are actively hostile
towards science you have some people
that just might not have heard of a
particular topic or concept before and
some people that might be interested in
science but just don't have very much
knowledge or understanding time to tell
you how these concepts are linked in
practice my personal philosophy for
producing cycom is this
firstly pick a learning objective how do
i want my audience's science capital to
have changed by the time i'm finished
secondly pick an initial level of
science capital so who is my audience am
i aiming for people who are already
interested in a topic or people who i
would like to interest in a topic
and then thirdly the really difficult
step
pick the format so the tv film youtube
video book
whatever and the style that maximizes
the probability of my chosen audience
reaching my chosen learning objective
ah
easy
once you have this concept of what your
project is it's then a simple question
of communicating your ideas to your
audience in the most engaging way
possible which is ultimately a question
of storytelling this is actually a whole
video on its own but suffice to say for
now that education is storytelling this
makes it sound very simple but of course
it's not it's very hard it's taken me
years to get to where i am now and i
fully acknowledge that i am decades
behind some other people in this field
with that said let's go back and look at
some of my old projects and see how i
put these concepts into action my phd
vlog series for those of you who are new
to the channel you may not know that i
vlogged the process of getting my phd at
the university of exeter the explicit
intent with these videos was to target a
low science capital audience that just
logs onto youtube to watch vlogs as
mindless entertainment by watching my
vlogs they were hopefully entertained
but also informed about how science is
done and about my research topic in
particular nowadays many of my videos
are video essays like the recent one on
the tongan shockwave this is aiming for
a middling to high science capital
audience so there's nothing terribly
complex in these videos and they're
constructed to match what other popular
science channels on youtube are doing
the logic being that the audience that
watches those videos is the level i want
to reach sometimes however i do a more
detailed science based video like the
one last year on building an ai to play
warhammer 40 000 against this is
definitely aimed at a higher science
capital audience but there's an
interesting bifurcation it's partly
aimed at people who want to see an
application of machine learning but also
at people who are just into warhammer
and interested if not terribly
knowledgeable about science
this is the kind of video that i find
particularly interesting because you're
kind of luring people in with the
promise of something they're interested
in but then introducing them to a
scientific aspect of it or an angle on
the subject and that means that you're
kind of operating at two different
levels of science capital one quite low
and one relatively high another example
of this would be my sci-fi planet series
with dr hannah wakeford a series that
was very intentionally constructed with
the idea of learning objectives and
science capital in mind but these are
all still just videos what about an
entirely different format
well let me now introduce you to a
project that i've been working on for a
couple of months with some seriously
talented friends and it's doing
something that as far as we know
is completely
unique
the rp geeks we spent so long should
have come up with the name for the rp
geeks 11 points of piercing damage i
only had eight hit points remaining
so
how did you only have eight because you
did ten times
oh like you the rp geeks like to take
the best bits of dungeons and dragons
and the best bits of science and combine
them together and hopefully if you're
interested in one you'll be interested
in what we're doing my name is ali
jennings my name is simon hi i'm emily
bates also i'm sharmini d5e is a fantasy
rule set it's a game that wants you to
do dragons and magic and all that kind
of stuff and we say there is no magic um
you can do everything that you can do in
5e as long as you can explain how it
would plausibly work
understanding the science behind
leveling up and dnd how do you how do
you explain five minutes
how would you explain the science of
leveling up what is your expectation
i play infinite sky 6000 who is a
terraforming druid droid excuse me you
seem like you might be in charge here um
i'm infinite sky 6000 serial number
eight six nine one nine seven two six
pmg
b1530ml and i was just wondering if you
could tell me what's going on and her
emotional suppressor is broken so she is
feeling things for the very first time
at the moment happiness and love but um
we'll see
she's getting angrier
catches sight of you and narrows their
eyes
they reach out and tug the shirt sleeve
of the person before they do that can i
just try
just like taking one hand off the rope
roll a persuasion check thank you i'm
very i'm very persuasive um that was a
25
yes
one
now she rolls well i play tinebrus um
according to the character sheet uh
she's a drow sorcerer obviously we have
explanations for her mysterious magical
powers
um and rather than a drow
she you know has a dark past it's all
very mysterious also simon key points i
hope you've learned how to use them yes
i
know which ones are my key points i
think it's decks and strength
no no
you know that right okay
stop it
in the campaign i play uriel boson who
is a dwarf monk who uh has basically in
our version of the d d rules is a human
who has been cybernetically enhanced so
he's actually more similar to a dwarf
and he's tough and resistant to things
but he also knows about metal work
and he's on an interesting journey of
transitioning if you like from being
human to being more machine than man
in front of you there are six tables so
a row of three
and a row of three behind that
and then behind those is the bar
it sounds like you're just wearing a
battle map yeah that's no worries
yeah like i'm like i can really picture
that
what is a dungeon what isn't a dungeon
master basically the person who makes
the entire world and then they ask the
players to come in and explore that
world our characters arrive in a place
called val which is a mining colony that
sits just in the shadow of these
mountains they're asked to find some
smugglers and stop them they
travel up to the mine looking for these
smugglers they get attacked on the way
by some sort of huge bird it's not clear
why the bird is so large but they get
attacked and survived they make their
way down into the mines picking up clues
as to
what might be happening they get
attacked and deep down buried there they
find something
very strange a wall of unearthly
radiance when they reach this wall
they find two of the smugglers trying to
do some sort of ritual they try and stop
them they fail and which is one of the
beauties of dnd is that you know you can
try and do something you could try to be
telling a story a certain way but how
the dice go what the characters decide
to do you don't know they could fail and
then they ran and this wall emitted this
burst of radiant heat and light melting
things bringing down the whole cavern
fell down a ravine again completely
unexpected and then ended up meeting
some fish people
and being ejected down into the forest
and from there
via a few scrapes they've eventually
made it back uh to the place where they
began but they've in doing so they've
learnt a huge amount more about the
world and about what's going on inside
and since we recorded these interviews
there has been yet more story including
us hijacking a spaceship made of enamel
that we naturally called the tooth fairy
the learning objective here is to make
science more enjoyable and more
interesting increasing awareness across
a wide range of subjects our audience is
low science capital people who just like
tabletop and role-playing games just
like my planet's videos that is what
initially interests people and the way
we talk about the science is hopefully
what makes people stay and what
increases their science capital so the
rpgs go live every wednesday on twitch
at 7 pm on twitch.tv forward slash dr
simon clark and then we're on many
social media networks at rp geeks dnd
we've been running this project under
the radar for quite a few months now as
we've been tinkering and working out
what format works best and now we're
really happy with it hence why i'm
sharing it with you all science is
fundamental to the way we live our lives
and a public that is aware of interested
in hearing about and knows enough about
to form opinions on science is a public
that makes smarter decisions that funds
further research to push our knowledge
even further and lives a more fulfilled
wonder-filled life that's why this is
important and it's why if you're talking
about science you have to think about
how you're doing it
what is your learning objective who are
you trying to reach and how can you
reach them most effectively
once you've worked all of this out all
you need to do is
tell them a story so education is
storytelling and that means that if you
want to educate you have to learn how to
tell a good story and by that i don't
mean being engaging on camera
i mean learn how to structure a good
story there is an art form with an
established set of effective conventions
that you won't even notice if they're
applied properly like in early game of
thrones but are really noticeable if
they're not applied properly like in
late game of thrones traditionally you'd
learn these conventions at an expensive
film school but now they're accessible
to everyone for example writer and actor
joshua dickinson teaches the
fundamentals in his beginner-friendly
course on skillshare this video's
sponsored josh talks through concepts
like the three-act structure conflict
and character arcs that you may think
are only relevant to movies and novels
but i can assure you are fundamental to
telling a good story in non-fiction too
now you could be forgiven for thinking
great another service i have to pay for
but skillshare is offering my viewers a
30-day free trial and in that time you
will find course after course on
subjects that you've always wanted to
learn but you never quite got around to
trying there's jazza teaching
illustration brett harned teaching
project management and my friend ali
abdul showing you how to create a side
hustle while you may have a specific
skill in mind that you want to develop
like say storytelling if you're anything
like me you'll spend a bit of time on
skillshare and see several courses where
you think oh i've actually always wanted
to learn how to do that the first 1000
people to go to the link in the
description will get themselves a free
month of skillshare an amazing
opportunity to pivot in your career
develop a skill like revision or simply
follow your creative curiosity check out
that link in the description and thank
you again to skillshare for sponsoring
this video thank you so much for
watching the video i really hope you
enjoyed this one and all of these recent
videos as they're getting a bit bigger
and a bit more ambitious now that i have
more time thanks to my lovely editor
helping me out here's some recommended
viewing next if you're not already
please do subscribe to the channel so
you get notified when new videos come
out and if you enjoyed this video please
do pop it a like that just leaves me to
say thank you again for watching and
i'll see you
in the next one